North Carolina state representative
Trisha cotham who ran as a Democrat has
switched to being a republican this
pushes the North Carolina House of
Representatives to a veto proof majority
for Republicans many of you have written
in saying David this is fraud she needs
to be kicked out or recalled my reading
of the law is that there is no recall
provision for a state rep in North
Carolina and unless you can demonstrate
that she planned to do this at all along
or maybe conspired with Republicans I
think you have a very hard time getting
rid of her from her position disagree
with me let me know in the comments